you have any idea what a phenomenon this
show was gonna become um you know you
can't really plan for something like
that we we had high hopes we had really
high hopes the Archie comics kind of
exists as a cultural undercurrent if you
just grow up in the United States and in
Canada everyone knows names of the
characters everyone understands who
Jughead and Archie and Betty and
Veronica are and so I guess we kind of
extrapolated a little bit from that and
hoped it it would have yielded a kind of
a kind of craze around it but we we took
a risk I mean we tried to reduce the
risk as much as possible by by having
these characters still represent
fundamentally what they represented in
the comics but this was something that
was brand new for for Archie Comics
comic book fans are oftentimes purists
so breaking through to that crowd can be
really intimidating if it's if it's a
kind of new take on it but we had hopes
that through the kind of quality of our
cinematography and and how over-the-top
the writing could be that it would just
be a fun viewing experience and people
enjoyed it they do enjoy and I was a
saint of Robin earlier there's two ways
the show could have gone when I first
heard they were doing based on Archie
comics you know it could have been
sugary-sweet
yeah and this is dark and sexy and you
know there is a version of me I'm not
gonna lie there is a version of me that
wants to see like our troupe our theater
troupe of Archie characters very Mad Men
style of 50s super brooding and silent
and there's a part of me that still
wants to see that so you know I'm just
making a plug why do you think it's
important the show obviously deals with
things that you know there's rape drugs
jingle-jangle how sick of you I was sick
of saying jingle-jangle
are you it's I think when we first got
that script we all passed texts to
Roberto like a thousand times going are
you serious with this we were laughing
about it for the
first couple weeks but it's you know
it's one of those things in the show
that it it is making a nod towards the
comics always and it's it's like season
one we had syrup as one of the primary
antagonists of season one so after that
jingle jangle it's just another welcome
addition to the party what's up what's
coming up in season two that fans of the
show can look forward to it's obviously
I found season two is getting a bit even
darker than the first season it's a
little more twisted there's a lot going
on what's coming up that fans can be
excited about I think for me from from
an actor's perspective we the success of
season one has given us a lot more
freedom to dive into more more topical
narratives more I guess the kind of
genre elements and the tones that we
were only dipping a toe into last season
so that's what I'm most excited about
and I think with the fan shooting the
most excited about two is that we've
we've been allowed to really dive into
the cinematography and and the kind of
neo-noir tones that we were pushing a
little bit in the first season in a way
that is much more interesting to me and
that's aside from the narratives itself
is there a certain plot line that she
would love to see jughead go through in
the second season I I think Chuck had in
the in the first half of this season
jugheads narrative is very much in
preparation for the latter half of the
season which is this kind of this
bubbling impending Civil War between the
north and the south of Riverdale and I'm
excited to see that narrative come to to
fruition and what that sort of means for
his character who's had who's had a
hands on both sides and see what that
means for him
as as a person who's tried to remain a
conscientious objector well what what
that means for his agency and what that
means for him being forced to take
action